[Música]
porque desde hoy martes 16 de noviembre
se exige el carnet de vacunación en
colombia para eventos masivos y algunos
establecimientos lo requerirán en bares
gastrobares cines discotecas conciertos
casinos entre otras actividades de ocio
también se pedirá para la entrada a
escenarios deportivos parques de
diversiones parques temáticos museos
ferias y también iglesias pese a esto
hay colombianos que se siguen negando a
ser inmunizados por la desconfianza la
vacuna la medida a servirá para evitar
mayores contagios justo cuando se acerca
la temporada navideña de reuniones y
fiestas esta pregunta se la quiero
trasladar a rodrigo córdoba psiquiatra
profesor e investigador de la
universidad de rosario en bogotá
colombia gracias a rodrigo por estar
aquí con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24
esta medida realmente entonces va a
servir para evitar mayores contagios en
la temporada navideña
muy buenos días un gusto saludarlos sin
duda yo creo que aquí hay dos factores
que hay que tener en cuenta es cierto
que un país esté colombia es un país de
derechos y quizás la fortaleza de la
democracia es es la dignidad y los
derechos en ese sentido la capacidad de
una persona
decidido de ser autónoma en sus
peticiones
siempre debe ser considero pero frente a
una situación tan dramática conocido la
pandemia por política y perú y que lo
único que ha mostrado que disminuye la
velocidad las tasas de contagio y la
cantidad
dramática de género en algún tiempo como
fue en una cifra de mortalidad que nos
producían escozor a diario en que
todavía se siguen presentando creo que
sin lugar a dudas debe primar el bien
común sobre el bien individual y por lo
menos quienes quieran ir a este tipo de
actividades pues deben presentar su
carnet de vacunación es decir deben
haber cumplido
por ese requisito
ahora le pregunto rodrigo si es
necesario exigir este carnet de
vacunación y qué le dice entonces a las
personas que de alguna manera u otra no
quieren vacunarse debido a creencias que
no creen en esta vacuna porque es
necesario no estarían también entonces
violando los derechos individuales de
esta persona siendo un poco abogado del
y yo entiendo la preocupación y entiendo
la preocupación de muchos y viendo las
creencias los fundamentos que a veces se
vuelven fundamentalismos y eso pueden
ser sumamente respetable
y quizás valorable pero lo que sucede si
alguien quiere entrar a un templo
japonés
y sabe que tiene que quitarse los
zapatos que alguien quiere ir a un
restaurante y fuma pues sabe que para
fumar tiene que hacerlo a fuerte en este
caso en un sentido de la protección para
los otros ciudadanos pues es importante
garantizar que todos estén vacunados
porque aquí además de las creencias los
puntos de vista las convicciones está la
dada la evidencia científica es decir la
fortaleza de los datos y un reciente
estudio del lance ha mostrado que seis
veces las personas vacunadas están
mayormente protegidas para que se
contagien y aún para proteger su vida a
futuro entonces frente a la fortaleza de
los datos las posibilidades que hay
observe esto otro externo puede evaluar
estos resultados y les confieren
confiables es creo que es una situación
absolutamente superior a las ideas
personales oa las creencias que lo pasan
por el el pedazo de la 7a hora también
rodrigo aquí hay un punto pues un poco
delicado de alguna manera porque si bien
es cierto que el gobierno puede pues
hacer esta ley de salud pública de
política pública en cuanto a esta crisis
de salud que estamos viviendo en todo el
mundo de vacunarse para poder entrar a
un lugar también este carné de
vacunación se le va a exigir a menores
de edad entonces el gobierno en alguna
manera también pues tiene la potestad de
poder exigir entre comillas la
vacunación a los hijos de las personas a
los menores de edad como también se
puede hablar sobre esto
yo diría si le alcanzó a dar normalmente
no es funcionario público ni funcionario
del gobierno sino es mi sentido común yo
pienso que la medida lo que intenta es
generar la capacidad de proteger en los
lugares donde existen mayores
posibilidades de contar que es donde
existe mayor concentración y
aglutinación de dónde está absolutamente
demostrado que a través del aire y las
partidas es que se transmite el kobe 19
entonces en este sentido pues ésta
estaría en la obligación así como
alguien no se quiere vacunar y creo que
no lo van a correr de la mano y llevarlo
a una estación de policía que se ha
vacunado
también pues esa persona sabe que se
tiene que privar de ese tipo de espectro
pero si bien es cierto que también
podríamos volver a un nuevo
confinamiento como le estamos viendo en
europa que hay varios países que ya
estaban confinando a las personas no
vacunadas
cuál sería digamos el beneficio
vacunarnos que sería mejor porque volver
a un nuevo confinamiento afectaría de
nuevo a nuestra salud sobre todo en esta
temporada navideña cuando queremos
reencontrarnos con nuestras familias
cómo afectaría un nuevo confinamiento a
nuestra sociedad
no es sin duda el confinamiento creo que
ha mostrado
impacto sobre la salud mental y la salud
física del 2 y sin duda todas las
repercusiones en el orden de lo social
de lo socioeconómico de las personas
entonces allí
vemos que un nuevo complica miento pues
sin lugar a dudas trae una repercusión
importante 30 por ciento aumentado las
demandas de la atención en salud mental
con cuadros críticos ya claramente
definidos aún de los conocidos como la
depresión la ansiedad los trastornos
obsesivos compulsivos el trastorno por
estrés postraumático y una serie de
cuadros médicos muy particulares que no
hemos logrado definir pero que son las
secuelas que deja al cob y 19 pero
además de ellos sobre la salud física
que ha traído consecuencias importantes
es decir 25 por ciento ha dejado algún
tipo de secuelas pero también si tú ves
el impacto sobre el retardo pero no es
de colombia es del mundo sobre la
economía desarrollos sociales han traído
pues todas estas muestras de violencia
de inseguridad es sin duda están
asociados a la pandemia y a las las
medidas que se tuvo que tomar para
intentar controlarlo
entonces ya quisiéramos pensar que no
tuviéramos que pensar nuevamente en
tiempos de
aislamiento o de aislamiento obligado de
cuarentena